today's video is brought to you by the
free to play multiplayer game enlisted
if you're a gamer you know that
historical shooters have come back into
vogue in the last four or five years and
enlisted which was launched in 2021 is
quickly becoming one of the most popular
games in the space it has a strong focus
on historical accuracy which we like
here while still keeping gameplay
dynamic at fast pace personally i like
games in this genre they build the
mechanics around history it's nice you
feel like you're learning something
while having fun you feel like you're
transported into the past to shoot some
stuff you could play distinct historical
campaigns like the invasion of normandy
or the battle of moscow each campaign
has unique maps troops weapons and all
kinds of various historical details to
unlock and play in enlisted has lots of
other elements from other shooters that
you probably enjoy like large-scale
combat zones with vehicles and
specialized weapons but it also has some
cool elements that are totally unique
like the ability to construct
fortifications to assist your team in
real time on the battlefield naturally
there's full customization of your
soldier so you can take your preferred
style of fighter into battle naturally
enlisted's available on pc as well as
both xbox series x and ps5 as well as
xbox one and ps4 also everything's fully
optimized for cross-platform support so
there's lots of ways to join in the
battle and do remember it's free to play
thanks again to enlisted for sponsoring
today's video remember you can go to
enlisted dot link forward slash
biographics enlisted to start playing
their free mmo shooter and as a special
treat for you guys following that link
in the description box below we'll get
you three days of premium play for free
plus several orders for troops and
weapons it's very cool go check out
enlisted today link below now today's
video
during the mid-1930s famed mobster bugsy
siegel left new york and relocated to
los angeles to look after the mob's
interests in california the city
perfectly catered to siegel's love of
the good life lavish parties nice cars
expensive suits rubbing elbows with the
hollywood elite it was all right up
bugsy's alley and he practically
reinvented the image of the classic
mobster but he never did it alone
because throughout his entire time in
california mickey cohen was his shadow
while siegel was suave tall and handsome
and was able to conceal his dark side
from the general public mickey cohen was
a lot more what you see is what you get
a quick-tempered loud boisterous and
violent former boxer who has brought in
a seagulls bodyguard and quickly rose
through the ranks and the mob due to his
viciousness and willingness to do
whatever was necessary to get the job
done but cohen wasn't just some dumb
muscle when bugsy siegel was forced into
retirement mo greenstar with a bullet
through the eye a power struggle took
place and micky cohen emerged victorious
as the new king of los angeles
[Music]
mayor harris mickey cohen was born on
september 4th 1913 in brooklyn new york
the youngest of five children to max and
fanny cohen two orthodox jews who had
immigrated from kiev his father who was
a fishmonger died from tuberculosis a
year after mickey's birth putting
pressure on his mother to provide for
the family when mckee was six years old
she borrowed some money and relocated
from new york to los angeles setting up
in a russian jewish neighborhood in ball
heights where the cohen's opened a
pharmacy while the mother handled the
legitimate side of the drugstore
mickey's older brothers operated a small
gin mill enough to make a few extra
bucks once prohibition went into effect
this caught mickey his first taste of
life outside the law since he acted as
the delivery boy in the operation and
already he discovered that he rather
liked it he would later recall that he
enjoyed the sensation of having a big
wad of cash in his pocket and even when
he had only a few hundred bucks he would
keep them in singles and five dollar
bills to make the stack as thick as
possible even getting pinched by the
police when he was only nine years old
didn't scare him straight his brothers
got him off with a short stint in reform
school and then it became clear that
mickey cohen was not meant for a life
walking the straight and narrow school
meant very little to him and mickey
encountered little resistance for his
family when he dropped out altogether at
the age of just 10. his mother worked
upwards of 14 hours a day and barely saw
him while his older siblings all had
their own side hustles going and hadn't
exactly been valedictorian material
either his sister pauline was the only
one who tried to guide mickey onto a
more righteous and straightforward path
but to no avail when he wasn't
bootlegging mickey worked as a news boy
and soon realized that the job was a lot
more physical than one would expect he
constantly had to fight with other news
boys in order to work the best street
corners and that's how mickey discovered
he was pretty good when it came to
swinging his fists he started boxing
taking part in unofficial cards
throughout the city to supplement his
income in 1929 the 15 year old mickey
moved to cleveland ohio and started
training for a legitimate boxing career
he had his first professional match on
april the 8th 1930 billed as irish
mickey cohen for some reason although
sometimes he went by gangster mickey
cohen the fight was a win against patsy
farr and maybe for a time cohen thought
that a prize-fighting career might be on
the cards of him that idea however was
dropped like a lead balloon in 1931 when
cohen faced off against future world
featherweight champion tommy paul and
paul knocked him out so hard that cohen
had to be carried to the locker room
while little stars circled around his
head
we assume we're not doctors anyway it
became clear that cohen wasn't
championship material but that did not
mean he was ready to give up on his
career completely according to boxing
records cohen had his last fight on
september 6 1935 against tracy cox he
finished with a record of 8-16-5 8 wins
16 losses five draws but considering how
common match fixing was back then it's
impossible to tell how many of these
results were actually legit that being
said fixing fights did of its benefits
because it introduced the up and coming
boxer to some members of the underworld
therefore when cohen decided that life
inside the squared circle wasn't for him
he already had a new career lined up
after he received a drumming from tommy
paul the quality of cohen's boxing
fights decreased sharply he turned from
a promising pugilistic prospect into one
of the many downtrodden low card tomato
cans who didn't know where their next
meal was coming from during the great
depression smaller fights meant smaller
purses which in turn meant that cohen
needed to find new ways to make money he
had a few pals started holding up
bookies speakeasies and other shady
joints not realizing that most of the
places here were owned by the mob cohen
got it easy though because the gangsters
he targeted had an eye for talent so
instead of making him sleep with the
fishes they put him on the payroll
mickey cohen was now an enforcer with
the cleveland mob but this role was
short-lived after beating the rap on an
armed robbery charge cohen decided it
was best to lay low for a while so he
relocated to the windy city where he
became part of the chicago outfit cohen
claimed to have received a personal
endorsement from al capone himself who
first greeted him by grabbing cohen's
head in his hands and kissing him on
both cheeks however al capone was
imprisoned in early 1932 so those years
don't exactly line up to be honest
cohen's timeline throughout the whole
1930s is a bit screwed up suffice to say
that he bounced around between cleveland
chicago new york and los angeles in that
decade the exact years are uncertain
back in chicago cohen mainly handled
gambling operations running card games
and crap tables for the capone's he knew
he made it into the big leagues when he
survived his first assassination attempt
the first of many by the way here is how
cohen described the event i had on a
camel hair coat the boy i was really in
love with and i think this was the
second time i had worn it so when they
came by shooting i didn't even fall
because i didn't want to get my coat
dirty once again it was decided that it
would be better for cohen to seek safer
pastures so he returned to cleveland
where he ran with bootlegger lou
rothkopf for a while but bootlegging
wasn't what he used to be now that
prohibition was over so rothkopf
introduced cohen to some of his new york
associates including mayor lansky and
lucky luciano since they were always on
the lookout for new muscle and as it
happened they had the perfect job in
mind for mickey
[Music]
in 1939 micky cohen moved back to los
angeles with the task of acting as
bodyguard to bugsy's eagle by that point
the commission had formed and the
national crime syndicate was in full
effect lucky luciana was the most feared
man in new york city while mayor lansky
and bugsy siegel were two of his
strongest allies and if you're not
really sure what that means maybe you
should check out our videos we did on
each of them because we went in depth
with the formation of the commission in
those videos so we're not going to
retread the same ground here surprised
to say the bugsy siegel arrived in los
angeles with the full support of the new
york families with the goal of bringing
organized crime in southern california
into the 20th century that's not to say
that los angeles didn't have his own
crime family it did and this was run by
a man named jack dragner but dragner was
one of those old school sicilians who
still ran the same rackets that had been
around for decades even shaking down
immigrants who came into the city he
didn't have the business acumen of mayor
lansky the vision of lucky luciano the
muscle of al capone or the political
connections of frank costello as one mob
historian put it dragner rose to the top
among the homegrown california mobsters
only because he was the best of a poor
lot but that was simply not good enough
anymore and jokers like siegel and cohen
were there to give los angeles a better
class of criminals this didn't mean
all-out war though dragner simply didn't
have the muscle for it even though he
had the backing of the chicago outfit
instead he just had to grin and bear it
as he entered into a not so friendly
rivalry with the new yorkers while
siegel was mostly busy delegating orders
and hanging out with movie stars mickey
cohen was the one who led boots on the
ground robberies narcotics gambling
prostitution murder he was involved in
all of it and that's not taking into
account their legitimate businesses
which ranged from fancy dinner clubs to
ice cream trucks one of the most
lucrative operations that the two sides
fought over was the race war the wire
service used by bookies for scores and
race results dragner backed the
continental press service owned and
operated by one of his associates james
reagan while cohen and siegel pushed
their own transcontinental wire
eventually cohen decided to put a
permanent end to the feud by raising the
continental press office beating up
everyone inside and tearing out the
phone lines reagan got the message loud
and clear he abandoned the business and
left los angeles fearing for his life he
was gunned down in 1946 in chicago his
killer never being identified cohen had
several run-ins with the cops during
this time he was arrested or questioned
on multiple occasions including for two
murders but none of the cases ever went
to trial cohen liked to brag in private
that it cost him 40 grand to get away
with murder on a personal level micky
cohen married lavon weaver in 1940 and
the couple stayed married for 18 years
with no kids once he began mingling
among the cream of the crop cohen
started feeling a little self-conscious
about his illiteracy and his boorish
behavior even though he remained
ill-tempered and quick to fly off the
handle his entire life cohen had a
private tutor to teach him better
manners and basic schooling so he could
better fit in he adapted well to the
hollywood lifestyle especially as siegel
became more and more concerned with
opening the flamingo casino in las vegas
but 1947 proved to be a pivotal year for
mickey cohen following years of poor
management and skimming funds in vegas
the syndicate could no longer tolerate
siegel's blunders on june 20th 1947
bugsy was shot dead in his beverly hills
mansion which immediately begged the
question who would replace him as the
new kingpin of los angeles
once siegel was out of the picture it
was business as usual for everyone else
guys like moe sedway and joseph statcher
took over his casino just hours after
his murder while kern received the
go-ahead from the syndicate to handle
his businesses in los angeles in his
autobiography cohen admitted that
although he liked bugsy his
assassination proved to be mickey's big
break in the mob soon enough mickey
cohen was the new big boss of la and now
he was the one meeting with hollywood
execs and partying with famous
celebrities but his position was far
from secure up to that point bugsy
siegel's presence had kept other rivals
at bay but his death showed that nobody
was truly untouchable therefore it
wasn't really a surprise when jack
dragner decided that he wanted his spot
at the head of the table back and he was
willing to go to war to get it each man
had his own advantages mickey cohen was
the one chosen by the syndicate and he
had the support of the commission back
in new york but that was literally on
the other side of the country and
couldn't be counted on all the time
meanwhile dragner was still in good
standing with the chicago outfit but not
good enough that they would be willing
to go to war with new york for him his
biggest asset was his connections with
the los angeles police since he had
decades-old relationships with all the
crooked cops in the city remember when
we said earlier that mickey cohen
survived his first assassination attempt
of many while working for the capones in
chicago well now it's time for all the
rest and frankly it's miraculous that
mickey cohen ended up dying of natural
causes there were so many close calls
that it showed that cohen had mr magoo
levels of good luck and that jack
dragner strictly employed stormtroopers
with astigmatism as hired gunmen for
example one of the first attempts on
cohen's life was an ambush while he was
driving home even though several gunmen
unloaded on his car with shotguns and
tommy guns none of them hit anything
cohen fell to the floor of his cadillac
and drove it blind down wilcher
boulevard and not only did he escape
with just a few scrapes from broken
glass he didn't even manage to hit
anything after this event cohen got
himself a custom-made bulletproof
cadillac fitted with eight-inch thick
armor-plated doors on a different
occasion kern was coming out of a joint
and headed towards his car while
unbeknownst to him a sniper was lining
up his shot cohn stopped suddenly and
bent down to inspect a scratch on the
fender at which point a bullet flew over
his head and hit his precious cadillac
once again a different sharpshooter was
more successful since at least he
managed indicon by hitting him in the
arm while the mob boss had lunch at a
diner unfortunately after the original
shot didn't take down its target the
sniper began unloading indiscriminately
injuring several innocent diners as well
as killing one of cohen's associates but
without a doubt the most preposterous
assassination attempts were the ones
inside cohen's own home first dragner
managed to sneak a world war ii
bangalore torpedo inside the house it
was a long and thin explosive used by
combat engineers to clear obstacles but
on this particular occasion the charge
didn't go off then on another occasion
jagmar's men planted an old-fashioned
bomb underneath cohen's bedroom and this
time it actually detonated there was
just one problem though cohen wasn't in
his bedroom his alarm had gone off
telling him that there were intruders on
his property so he was sneaking around
through the downstairs living room when
the explosion happened cohen later
observed that his neighbors got it worse
than him since the concussion blast
faced their house but he also bemoaned
that the explosion took out most of his
expensive wardrobe still this was the
sixth attempt in four years and those
are just the ones that made the press
and while cohen himself kept surviving
the same couldn't be said for the people
around him several henchmen either
disappeared or were killed during these
years and even the mobster's attorney
was gunned down in front of his own home
there weren't enough bribes in the world
to hush up this kind of violence so in
1950 the u.s senate formed a special
committee to investigate organized crime
many mob bosses cohen included were
called to testify on the cafalva
hearings as they became known and it was
all televised giving many americans
their first exposure to the world of the
mafia mickey cohen got off scot-free
following the cafalba hearings but he
was now firmly on the radar of the
authorities and they began investigating
him for all sorts of nasty business
ultimately they got him using the old
faithful of mob convictions tax evasion
and mickey cohen was sentenced to five
years in prison
mickey cohen was released from prison in
late 1955 after he got nine months off
for good behavior during his time behind
bars cohen generally kept a low profile
trying to avoid getting into trouble and
he read a lot of books in an attempt to
make up for his lack of childhood
education that being said once he was
out he was eager to re-enter la's
underworld and reclaim his spot at the
top of the food chain this was
surprisingly easy to do in the time he
had been locked up los angeles police
cracked down an organized crime so
nobody was really able to take his place
furthermore kern received a wonderful
present just a few months after his
release when his arch enemy jack dragner
died of a heart attack therefore mickey
encountered little resistance on his way
to the top and in fact he became even
more of a public figure during his
second stint as a mob boss he developed
strange and publicized friendships with
evangelist billy graham and the hearst
publishing family and he raised funds
for several prominent politicians but it
was a bizarre feud with actress lana
turner that garnered him the most
attention in the press lana turner had
been married to one of cohen's trusty
sidekicks a guy named johnny stompinato
but unsurprisingly stomato was a violent
hot-tempered man who subjected turner to
frequent physical and mental abuse one
night in 1958 things got so bad that
lana's 14 year old daughter cheryl crane
stepped in to protect her mother and
stabbed dompinato to death during a
highly scandalous and publicized inquest
the death was ruled justifiable homicide
solana and cheryl were off the hook
cohen however didn't like how his friend
had been portrayed by the media so he
went on a smearing campaign against
turner he released private letters
between lana and johnny and was one of
the main people who forwarded the
conspiracy theory that somebody else
actually killed stompanato that night
and that the daughter took the blame so
that they'd get away with it
unfortunately for cohen his time back as
the boss ended abruptly because in 1951
he was found guilty of tax evasion again
and sentenced to another 15 years he was
sent to the notorious alcatraz but only
spent a short while there before being
released on bail while his appeal was
pending the appeal failed in 1963 but by
then alcatraz closed down as a prison
and became a museum so cohen was sent to
the federal penitentiary in atlanta this
was cohen's life for the next decade
early on into his sentence he survived
one final assassination attempt when
another inmate burl estes macdonald
bludgeoned him with an iron pipe and
cracked his skull causing cohen to get a
steel plate fitted inside his head the
attack left the once mighty mob boss
permanently disabled and he needed a
cane to move around from then on kern
was released from prison in 1972 once
again getting time off for good behavior
and because he was suffering from
stomach cancer which had been originally
misdiagnosed as an ulcer it'd be fair to
say that this was somewhat of a farewell
tour for cohen who knew that he didn't
have long left to live gone were the
days when he was brushing off attempts
on his life in the pursuit of power and
wealth i was more interested in meeting
old friends catching a boxing match and
generally keeping a low profile he
actually made several television
appearances advocating against prison
abuse mickey cohen had one final and
bizarre brush with fame in 1974 when he
got involved in the infamous patti
hearst case when she was kidnapped by
the symbionese liberation army and
eventually joined her abductors cohen
claimed to have connections to the sla
and that he could attempt to negotiate
patty's release but his offer was
refused by the hearst family when it
became clear that patty had joined the
sla and that she risked prison mickey
cohen died on july 29 1976 age 62 of
complications from stomach cancer
surgery he reigned at the top of los
angeles underworld he survived 11
assassination attempts according to him
and even enjoyed a few years of peace
and quiet following his release from
prison and that was a lot more than what
most of its associates got
thanks again to enlisted for sponsoring
today's video head to enlisted dot link
forward slash biographics enlisted to
get started you get three free days of
premium time and some bonus troops and
weapons link below go check them out and
thanks for watching